well hopefully you're awake in front of
the TV right now 6 25 on your Monday
morning what's driving you crazy how
about another round of closures Lane
restrictions Nevada Department of
transportation's big project at
Charleston and the 95 515. so this is a
heads up for drivers who use Pecos under
the freeway starting tonight and running
every night until Friday morning at five
you're gonna have to find another way
now we're suggesting that you use Mojave
and even during the day when Pecos is
open under the 95 515 like it is right
now it will be closed tonight the
ongoing endot work is going to take
Lanes away in fact there's a ton of work
that's going to be going on all around
Charleston in the 95 515 until scheduled
completion in 2024. now all of this
information is at endos 515 Charleston
website we've got that link in the
online version of this story at
8newsnow.com any click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
8newsnow.com